We produce a lot of water and a kind of a shocking amount of it and gets lost.
Uh,
the quality matters.
So just like all those fuels had to go through numerous purification steps.
Obviously we want clean water for a,
whether it's drinking or chemical processes,
chemical processes may even be more sensitive than humans are to the wall water
quality,
uh,
in terms of chemistry versus society.
Uh,
water and energy are both competing against,
you know,
making a chemical versus keeping somebody warm and healthy and fed and
everything.
Water has to be distributed across large distances.
It's directly tied to the environment and pretty much every way.
And uh,
the more you invest in it,
the more quality you get.
Just like,
you know,
fuels.
The more,
the more complicated your system,
you can get a nicer fuel out,
you know,
clean coal,
clean diesel,
whatever.
And then,
uh,
on the political side,
it's also very heavily regulated.
So,
and I think pretty much everyone has a good idea of that.
Water is,
a lot of things are competing for water.
Um,
as a chemist,
if we're doing a reaction that needs a little bit of water,
that,
you know,
that's really important to us,
but,
uh,
you know,
people in other parts of the world are having to deal with water for a lot more
critical things to them.
Industrial water is just one of one box out of many,
many,
uh,
boxes and the overall,
water cycle.
So we have to be pretty cognizant of if we're going to set up a chemical process
that uses water or in fact just uses energy at all,
how that's going to affect these other applications.
So again,
just like energy,
the,
the critical drivers that there's just not a lot of water for increasing demand.
So,
uh,
although there's plenty of ocean water,
pretty much everybody wants groundwater and freshwater for chemical processes as
well as drinking and basic needs and the amount of fresh water that's available
looks like a pretty big number.
But then when you start to look at,
uh,
this,
this is a number just for the u s itself,
how much we process or touch in some way.
Uh,
every year these numbers are,
I mean,
they're five orders of magnitudes five orders of magnitude apart.
But if you consider just the quantity of water,
it's,
it's pretty impressive.
I think that we're affecting that much of the,
the global water supply.
And if you were to multiply this across the whole world,
this would obviously go up probably another order of magnitude.
And why that's important is that different parts of the world have different
access to water.
Sure.
Everybody's pretty familiar with that.
And so why this matters for chemicals is if you're producing,
say a chemical in India as opposed to producing a chemical in Canada,
uh,
if you're having a very water intensive process,
you're going to be having creating much larger impacts and some of these
countries as opposed to areas where the water is plentiful.
So the,
the national labs have produced the same kind of flow charts like we saw for
energy and they're kind of set up the same way.
So here are the sources over on the side,
uh,
surface water,
either fresh or salty and then groundwater,
fresh or salty,
and then the different uses.
So a domestic,
here's the,
the industrial use and then what happens to the water in the end?
So a lot of it just gets re,
uh,
discharged or,
spent,
uh,
discharge to the ocean and then either completely consumed or evaporated back
into the global water cycle.
And so if we look at the commercial and industrial cause this is where chemicals
are.
One of the important things is that a lot of it is being drawn from the public
water supply.
And the reason that's important is because the,
the public water supply is one of the most heavily purified system.
So it has all these embedded impacts associated with that technology.
So,
um,
you know,
we,
we don't just drink directly from the river.
It has to go through,
uh,
you know,
settling stages filtrations there's usually a chemical processes applied.
All those things have their embedded energy.
Some of those processes have their own water requirements.
And then for then finally it's getting into the industrial process,
which may be again tweaking it even further before or finally it gets released.
And just like we saw for energy with losses and transmission lines and we see,
uh,
arguably worse and water systems because a lot of the water infrastructure,
especially in the u s was built a hundred years ago,
if not earlier and has not been maintained very well.
So I'm
looking at some of the large water systems in the u s there's Philadelphia,
more than 30% of the water is just lost in the pipe system.
So they're applying,
they're extracting a lot of groundwater there are treating it.
And then a pretty large proportion of that is just going back into and to the,
um,
to places where it's not going to be used.
And,
I mean,
this is only a couple of water districts across the u s but you can start to
kind of consider the added up impacts from,
uh,
just the losses themselves and then the financial value if you're not entirely
motivated by the environmental impacts there clearly,
uh,
economic impacts that can be associated with this as well.